en este vídeo haremos algunos redondeos
con los que probablemente aún no estás
familiarizado pero verás que es bastante
sencillo y vamos a comenzar redondeando
a la decena más cercana entonces la
primera pregunta es qué es el redondeo y
por qué es útil bueno digamos que tienes
el número 37 es un buen número pero
digamos que tienes que hacer algunos
cálculos con el número 37 y puedes hacer
muchos cálculos con el número 37 pero
digamos que solo quieres hacer una
estimación digamos que si alguien dice
que tiene 37 pepinillos y tú tienes 39
pepinillos aproximadamente cuántos
tendrán entre los dos no tenemos que
saber el número exacto de pepinillos
pues bien el redondeo será una
herramienta muy útil pero concentrémonos
en lo que significa redondear a la
decena más cercana entonces cuando se
habla de redondear a la decena más
cercana estaremos pensando en la
posición de las decenas del número en
cuestión así que podemos ver justo aquí
en nuestra posición de las escenas que
tenemos un 3
este 3 representa tres decenas de modo
que el número 37 es tres decenas y siete
unidades así que es más de tres decenas
y va a ser menor que cuatro decenas
entonces este número va a ser más de
tres decenas podría hacerlo así serán
más de tres decenas y lo podemos
representar así tres decenas más cero o
tal vez sabes que es igual a 30 y será
menos de cuatro decenas o menos de
cuarenta y así cuando redondeadas
redondeadas al número de decenas que
está justo debajo de este número o al
número de decenas que está justo arriba
pero como sabemos si redondear 37 a la
decena más cercana va a ser igual a 30
oa 40
bueno para responder a esa pregunta
primero hagámoslo visualmente en una
recta numérica y así podemos obtener
algunas reglas para nosotros mismos en
primer lugar vamos a contar por decenas
y nos aseguramos de incluir 30 y 40
entonces y empezamos en cero
20 30 40 eso es suficiente
bueno podría ir a 50 solo para completar
esta recta numérica y entonces dónde
está el 37 en esta recta numérica bueno
está entre 30 y 40 y si quisiera aclarar
un poco si dijera que aquí tenemos 35
justo a la mitad de 30 y 40 entonces 37
estaría justo aquí entonces esto es 37
de modo que cuando redondea sala de
escena más cercana y recuerda estamos
escogiendo entre tres decenas y cuatro
decenas cual de escena es la más cercana
está más cerca de tres escenas o está
más cerca de cuatro decenas bueno puedes
mirar esto y decir que se ve mucho más
cerca de cuatro decenas y así en esta
situación 37 redondeado a la decena más
cercana va a ser igual a 40 y entonces
podrías decir bueno dame otro número qué
tal si alguien pide redondear 32 a la
decena más cercana
bueno 32 va a estar justo aquí y luego
dirías
eso está entre 3 y 4 decenas pero está
mucho más cerca de tres decenas por lo
que 32 redondeado a la decena más
cercana es igual a 30 ahora una pregunta
interesante que te podrías estar
haciendo es qué sucede si está en medio
que pasa si quisiéramos redondear 35 a
la decena más cercana 35 una vez más
está entre tres decenas y cuatro decenas
entre treinta y cuarenta a cual
redondeamos si queremos redondear a la
decena más cercana bueno la regla es y
esto realmente es algo que la sociedad
ha decidido es que si estás justo en
medio redondeadas hacia arriba por lo
que el número 35 se redondeará a 40 a
pesar de que está exactamente a 5
unidades de cada uno de estos números 35
se redondeará hacia arriba a 40 si
tienes un poco menos de 35 entonces
redondear as hacia abajo a 30 vamos a
hacer algunos ejemplos más hagamos un
ejemplo de un número de tres dígitos
donde redondeamos a la decena más
cercana
digamos que queremos redondear el número
124 a la decena más cercana bueno hay un
par de formas en que puedes pensar en
esto se podría decir que esto es una
centena dos decenas y cuatro unidades
incluso podrías ver esto como 12 decenas
y 4 unidades de modo que podrías decir
que esto está en medio 12 decenas y 4
unidades es mayor que 12 decenas que es
120 y es menor que 13 decenas que es 130
estas son las dos decenas que están más
cerca de este número y para decidir a
cuál de estas debemos redondear es
posible que ya puedan pensar en ello en
función de algunas de las reglas que
hemos establecido pero permítanme
dibujarlo en una recta numérica
dibujamos una recta numérica y no voy a
comenzar en cero porque tenemos que
llegar a 130 así que empecemos empecemos
en 100 entonces esto es 100 110 vamos a
tener 120 y luego 130 pondré 140 aquí
solo para completar la recta numérica
que dibuje
y luego dibujaré la marca de la mitad
que es 125 y luego 124 lo pondré de
color rojo 124 está justo aquí y si
estamos tratando de elegir entre 120 y
130 entre 12 y 13 decenas a cual está
más cerca bueno podemos ver que está
solo a 4 de 120 mientras que está a 6 de
130 así que redondeamos hacia abajo
vamos a redondear a 120 en esta
situación si estamos redondeando a la
decena más cercana si esto fuera 125 o
126 127 128 o 129 entonces redondear y
amos hacia arriba a 130 y por supuesto
si fuera 130 lo redondear y amos a 130
hagamos un ejemplo más y en realidad lo
voy a hacer con un número de un dígito
digamos que queremos redondear el 7 a la
decena más cercana lo escribiré
redondear 7 a la decena más cercana
pausa este vídeo y trata de resolverlo
de acuerdo entre cuales escenas hasta el
7 bueno 7 es menor que una decena
entonces es menor que una decena y es
mayor que cero decenas entonces está
entre cero decenas que es cero y una
decena que es diez pero a cuál se
redondea bueno aquí una vez más podemos
dibujar nuestra recta numérica entonces
vamos a poner el cero y luego aquí está
el 5 aquí está el 10 y 7 es justo aquí
ahí es donde está el 7 y visualmente
podemos darnos cuenta que 7 está más
cerca de 10 que de 0 está solo 13 10
mientras que a 7 de cero así que
redondear y amos hacia arriba a 10 o
puedes usar la regla que acabamos de
pensar 7 es mayor o igual que 5 entonces
redondea hacia arriba redondeada 10 que
es más grande que este número si este
número está en la posición de las
unidades si es mayor o igual que 0 pero
menor que cinco entonces redondeamos
hacia abajo y se puede ver que esto
sucede en todas estas situaciones si
tenemos el 36
y miras la posición de las unidades y la
posición de las unidades es mayor o
igual a 5 redondeadas hacia arriba aquí
si la posición de las unidades es mayor
o igual a 5 son 5 exactamente en esta
situación por lo que es igual a 5 una
vez más redondeadas hacia arriba si la
posición de las unidades es menor que 5
bueno en esta situación redondeamos
hacia abajo si la posición de las
unidades es menor que 5 redondeadas
hacia abajo la posición de las unidades
y aquí solo tienes la posición de las
unidades pero es mayor o igual a 5 lo
redondeamos hacia arriba hasta el
próximo vídeo